hola es excelente hablar con ustedes si
es una tragedia
que los pasos modestos que se habían
requerido para contener esta epidemia no
fuesen tomados en advance el avance
entonces dados millones de dólares de
daños y otro tipo de déficits que son
difíciles de medir deberíamos hacer la
inversión esos pequeños números millones
y que debemos asegurarnos a nosotros
para que eso no suceda de nuevo las
buenas noticias son que al hacer estas
inversiones podemos crear plataformas e
instalaciones que nos puedan ayudar de
manera inmensa contra enfermedades
infecciosas debemos conformar un equipo
de tres mil expertos globales
ellos pueden estar trabajando cosas como
malaria
y luego pasar a otras enfermedades como
esta pandemia así mismo en el área de
herramientas podríamos crear vacunas de
adn a que tengan capacidad global
fábricas que puedan ser usadas para
crear vacunas estándares cuando no haya
una pandemia quiero decir que podemos
tener metas muy ambiciosas
una vacuna universal para el coronavirus
así como una vacuna universal para la
gripe la posibilidad de hacer drogas que
bloqueen la transmisión y un
acercamiento diagnóstico que pueda hacer
que 20% de la población
mundial puede tener pruebas bajo costo
las herramientas estar en ese lado deben
recibir fondos y la capacidad de
instalación en la vigilancia las
fábricas el equipo de tres mil expertos
pero estas inversiones tendrán unos
retornos increíbles incluso cuando ya no
haya una pandemia tengo muy pocas dudas
de bueno
dada esta trama esta tragedia que ha
ocurrido en este momento
durante los próximos cinco años vayamos
a establecer estas cosas también
pregunta a usted sobre la equidad en
cuanto a repartición de vacunas la
creación de estas vacunas es realmente
un triunfo
tanto en cuanto a tecnología de vacunas
que fueron inicialmente avanzadas a
través del vih
la inversión que ha hecho nuestra
fundación y otras en el rn ha han
llegado bueno un alto porcentaje de
ellas han sido exitosas
pero la inequidad sigue siendo bastante
dramática una manera de resolverse en
equidad es hacer que las fábricas
lleguen a india que las fábricas del
ideas estén funcionando con completa
velocidad ya funciona con esa técnica ya
fusiona con otras dos organizaciones y
obtener los financiamientos tenemos que
ser agradecidos con alemania
que ha permitido que ocurra el tema de
kóvacs eeuu ingresó hace unos cuantos
meses de una manera significativa japón
canadá de hecho todo el g7
en los días que vienen hará unas
donaciones generosas para que la parte
financiera esté ahí los países ricos
obtienen sus altos niveles de vacunas
entonces sus fábricas pueden repartir
sus vacunas tendremos una delta de 68
meses de los niveles de vacunas para que
todo avance a los países en desarrollo
todavía no es como quisiéramos pero debo
decir que la cooperación
de las compañías farmacéuticas la
velocidad con la cual han progresado la
manera que los gobiernos sólo están
manejando sus autoridad y ahora están
diciendo calling
eso significa que tenemos una
oportunidad para romper esta brecha para
disminuirla
muchas gracias bills aquí está la
primera pregunta viene de unas sólidas
jóvenes de mi eric alexander campbell de
reducción
señor gates la falta de cooperación
entre gobiernos con grandes poderes a la
pandemia y maneras de que las empresas
en la parte competitiva contribuya de
esta manera sin importar el país de
origen o jurisdicciones cuál sería la
manera práctica para permitir tal
cooperación desde la empresa privada
muchas gracias
bill
bueno ciertamente necesitamos que los
gobiernos estén ahí cuando hay una
emergencia como esta el uno quiere
utilizar solamente señales del mercado
ah
porque los ciudadanos más ricos en los
países más ricos obtendrían todas las
capacidades y las instalaciones creo que
las compañías que hacen esto lo hacen de
una manera así sin beneficio pero
veamos la con el caso de fisher que
patrocinó sus propios esfuerzos de
gobiernos ayudan a proporcionar recursos
el gobierno de eeuu una parte de la
epidemia es beneficiada por esos avances
ejemplo eeuu cuando avanzan a toda
velocidad el otro gran patrocinó fuese
ping
que había empezado a trabajar después
del ébola con respaldo del reino unido
noruega a pont
y varias otras fundaciones y tenido la
misma el sector privado tiene la
capacidad
y el enlace entre fisher y bryant que es
un gran ejemplo de cooperación
transatlántica por ejemplo de hecho creo
que el rol del gobierno a la hora de
poner en lugar la preparación de la
pandemia puede ser un ejemplo brillante
de nueva cooperación trasatlántica e
incluso renovada cuando vemos distintas
piezas
[Música]
tanto en el campo de la investigación y
el terreno por el hecho de que los
filtros la filantropía de venga y actúa
de manera ágil nuestra fundación conoce
a los manufacturadores indios que hemos
contribuido a que haya en grandes
instalaciones allá eso fue muy útil y
salvo ayuda al menos seis meses y
adelantó el patrocinio pero no
deberíamos confiar en esto cuando se
trata del tema de las entregas
las organizaciones sin ánimo de lucro
están presentándose particularmente
en comunidades donde la confianza hacia
la vacuna es un desafío hacer que ellos
lleguen y animen a la gente para dar un
acceso fácil creo que eso incluso para
el próximo año va a ser muy importante